This is very interesting.
Donald Trump said during an interview this
week that, yes, he is planning to get people
a second stimulus check.
Trump was interviewed by Joe St George.
He was asked about a second stimulus check
and he said that that's the plan.
He wouldn't say when or for how much.
Let's take a look at that bit of the interview.
I have a lot of viewers in Florida, Ohio,
Wisconsin, Michigan, who are still struggling
economically, sir.
They spent all of that first stimulus check.
Are you gonna get them a second time?
Yeah, we are.
We are.
Look, we had this.
When when are you gonna get it?
We had this going better than anybody's ever
seen before.
We had the best job numbers, the best economics,
the best economy we've ever had.
And then we had the virus come in from China
and now we're rebuilding it again.
We will be doing another stimulus package.
It will be very good.
It will be very generous.
And how much, how much and how much people
want to know.
You'll find out about it.
You'll find out.
When are you going to do it?
When you get to announce?
I think over the next I think it's going to
be bipartisan.
I think it's going to be over the next couple
of weeks.
Now, this is fascinating for a few different
reasons.
You might remember that about a month ago,
maybe it was five weeks ago, it was pretty
clear that the Trump administration didn't
really have the appetite for another round
of payments and other stimulus check.
And I think that there were two reasons for
that.
First of all, there were so-called economic
concerns about the cost of doing another stimulus
check.
A lot of the people on Trump's side politically
are a so-called debt and deficit hawks, even
though they don't really understand those
those mechanisms economically.
But it seemed that that was part of the lack
of appetite.
But maybe even more importantly, they were
against committing to a second round of stimulus
checks four to six weeks ago because they
wanted to pretend that everything would be
fine by now and back to normal and that you
simply wouldn't need another round of stimulus
checks.
Now, of course, this is very much not the
case.
And in fact, a ton of people entitled to their
first check haven't even received it.
Thirty five million stimulus checks are still
outstanding as of mid-June.
And at the same time, Trump can't say or he
won't say how much money would be included
in the second stimulus.
And the reason he can't say that is the truth
is it's not clear that Republicans want to
do another round of stimulus.
And to me, this signals what's going on behind
the scenes.
Democrats want stimulus because Democrats
think people deserve it, given how bad the
situation with the Corona virus continues
to be.
Many Republicans don't want another stimulus
because their so-called debt and deficit hawks,
Trump only wants a second stimulus because
he sees the polls and he's panicking.
And as more checks go out, he envisions that
he is essentially buying himself more votes.
That's really what's going on here.
And there are even some officials in the Trump
administration that are not on board with
doing another round of stimulus.
It's not clear Republicans in the House are
going to go for it.
It's not clear Republicans in the Senate are
going to go for it either.
There have been some internal discussions
where Trump has said straight up he believes
sending out more checks will help boost the
economy and help him get reelected in the
fall like period.
Full stop, end of story.
Which is exactly what it seems to be to me.
Stephen Manoogian has been in favor of another
round of checks.
Trump's economic adviser, Larry Kudlow, seems
to have been opposed.
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has
been against another round of payments.
Democrats want even larger payments than the
first time around.
And Donald Trump here seems to be with the
Democrats, not for economic reasons, not for
moral reasons, but because he believes sending
checks out again will help get him reelected
in November.
Trump is effectively trying to buy his way
to reelection with another round of checks.
The right loves to attack the left as wanting
to buy people's votes with things like health
care and properly funded education, for example.
Now, those arguments are quite silly.
What we're talking about is establishing a
well-run society, given that we're one of
the richest countries in the world, much like
many northern European countries have been
able to do.
But Trump is actually saying allegedly behind
the scenes, if we start sending checks out
to people.
I'm going to get more people to vote for me.
Now, the other thing here is Trump may be
setting himself up to say, look, I wanted
another round of checks, but they wouldn't.
Okay, it.
They will be framed as Democrats, even though
here Democrats do want it.
And it seems like it's Republicans that aren't
actually interested in terms of the timing.
There's a bit of a conundrum.
July three to 17 is what's called a state
work period for the Senate, meaning they will
be in their states rather than in Washington,
D.C..
So what this means is there's.
No way this gets done before July 3rd.
I mean, we've got, you know, before July 3rd,
we have the next three days, then we've got
a weekend and then we have a few days next
week.
You're not going to pass another round of
stimulus checks before next Friday.
That means the conversation won't even really
be meaningful until after the Senate returns
after July 17th.
So if this process starts on July 17, when
could this even potentially be done?
Are we looking at August?
Are we looking at September?
And remember, thirty five million still haven't
gotten their first check or deposit, which
means that even if you get this passed in
late July or August, you could have people
who still will have not received their checks
until close to the presidential election in
November.
So I don't know whether it can even be done.
It doesn't seem Trump wants it for any reason
other than he sees it as a way to buy himself
some votes.
And we also have no idea what might even be
going on by the time that this actually gets
done in late July, early August.
We may not even have a break between waves
one and two in Corona virus as we see the
virus continues to rage in many states across
the country.
Very unpredictable.
But Donald Trump now panicking and saying,
yeah, yeah, yeah, let's get more checks to
people.
And a lot of this has to do with the polls,
which I want to talk about next